there's something different about him
now
and everybody matures as they get older
it's maybe it's a little of that but
it's there's a confidence
there's a self-assuredness in the way
that he speaks right and and and i i
asked him when the moment was in the off
season when
when he decided
that that he's going to basically go for
it that he's going to go all in and bet
on himself and he said that in the early
days of the pandemic when free agency
went forward and the bears traded for
nick foles that was when he
self-reflected or as we would say
self-reflected on himself the
on on what he wants to be on what he
wants his nfl career to be on what he
wants his career in chicago to be and he
became determined at that point to put
in the work put in the effort and prove
to everyone specifically his teammates
and his coaches that he's the best
option and he went about his business
and you know that when they didn't pick
up the option that was just more fuel to
the fire and he told me that all
throughout training camp he had no idea
that he was winning he didn't even care
that he was in position he was just
doing what he had to do they were
getting equal reps and it wasn't until
the afternoon that the news got out that
he'd won the job that he knew that even
had an inkling he said i wasn't worried
about it there's nothing i can't control
it right i'm focusing on what i can
control and i'll wait until they tell me
what they want me to do and and you know
look has he been perfect the first two
weeks no but they've won yes they have
and
there's something he said for that yeah
there's so that's right he's making
plays when he has to right and uh you
know they they came back from 17 down
they tried to blow the lead yesterday
but at the end of the day they they got
it done and let me tell you this too
about nick foles because we thought nick
foles was brought in because he knows
the offense and that had a lot to do
with it it gave him a building edge
but what trubisky said is that foles
because of all the other offenses he's
been a part of
he's bringing to the table yeah sure all
these things he's picked up elsewhere
and he's making their offense better and
the way trubisky put it is he defends
the quarterback position in that he's
doing what he can to make the
quarterback in that offense on that team
as good as it can be even if he's not
that quarterback yeah and it's like part
coach part player but he went on and on
about what nick foles has done and uh i
think he was the perfect guy to bring in
because hey maybe he wins the job fine
if he doesn't though he's not going to
be resentful he's not going to be petty
he's not going to be trying to sabotage
anything he's going to try to make
mitchell trubisky into the best
quarterback he possibly can be yeah i i
mean you're right we've heard this over
and over from nick falls and when you
get a quarterback a veteran quarterback
like that plus a a head coach or a play
caller that's willing to listen to ideas
and things like that man
that is awesome and especially when
you're the starter because not only you
sitting there listening these
conversations and you're you're learning
football but you know we've talked about
this other times sometimes you don't
know what you don't know in the nfl you
know i've i talked to some quarterbacks
and they just go i don't understand
how is new england getting that guy open
all the time i see them run this play
and
you know you want to sit there and
explain well they're coaching something
different than what you're you're not
you're your team's not coaching it the
right way sorry that's that's why
uh so that that's the interesting thing
there and yeah you know there comes a
time as a player mike i just will just
to my own life and i've seen it with my
father where you just you kind of get
boxed in the corner of your career and
you're going uh oh like where was i
going here and you just for lack of a
better pray
phrase just say eff it like f it screw
everybody i'm gonna i i want to play
football i want to be great the hell
with the media the hell with my head
coach you might want to replace me
i'm like i've just had enough of it and
there's that point where you hit as an
athlete or a competitor where all of a
sudden it just all the noise can go away
and you just start to focus on what's
you know what's really important and
that's when you can take off as a player
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports